what thoughts do you have for people who
feel like they're having trouble getting
their scripts
out there and getting seen getting read
what advice
i'm having the same problem i think the
problem is finding the right
person to um to send it to
if your script is about like a murder
mystery you're not gonna send it to a
romantic comedy company
so like you just have to and each of our
stories are so specific and so
authentic to our experiences you just
have to
find the right match uh once you find
the right match
then it's great so i think the homework
your work in addition to finishing the
story
and getting the story to the best shape
possible
the next step is to find the right
company
or the person to send it to so the
frustrations
probably comes from that sending it to
the wrong people
not doing the homework to send to the
right people yeah
are you in that position now or you're
working on right now i'm focusing on
finishing my project right now i you
know i feel i feel like
it's it's not good to send anything out
that is not ready so um that's another
thing that
a lot of people a lot of people mistake
that people make
that send out stuff that's not ready you
have one chance so you
you better make sure that a project gets
in amazing shape before sending out to
people to who are going to consider your
project
so yeah so i am focusing right now on
my feature film right now with script
when it's ready then i'll send it out
do you have an idea of when it will be
ready i give myself
this rewriting process this process
by the end of september so i have about
three months to finish
rewriting the script uh and then
probably a couple rewrites before i send
it out so this is
my second rewrite will you give it to
anyone else to to look over i
will send it to i have a group of people
that i trust
um i will send it to
a handful of people that i trust um that
are
that will give me truthful authentic
advice and feedback um
yeah don't give it to people
your family members yeah who always say
good things about it
don't give it to actors who wants to be
in the film
to give it to people you know i mean
just make sure that those people have no
conflict or any kind of vested interest
in being the project whatever someone
you trust someone who knows what they're
talking about
um and i have about like five or six
people like that that would
give me their authentic real advice and
feedback
that are constructive are they also
writers
some writers some actors some producers
you